empty classrooms
and empty playgrounds and nursery
schools
it's pretty much the same picture around
the world
to curb the number of coronavirus
infections schools and kindergartens
remain shut
when can they open again and if so under
what conditions
that's the question most parents ask
children need an education
but they also need to be protected from
the virus
a difficult balancing act
[Music]
welcome to our kobe 19 special on dw
news i'm monica jones and berlin good to
have you with us
it's 2021 and the pandemic still
dictates our life
and that of our children of course now
there's talk of prolonging the lockdown
again
no school no kindergarten but are kids
really at risk
a recent study implies yes they are
children are generally not considered to
be driving the spread of the coronavirus
but researchers in munich analyzed blood
samples from twelve
thousand children and what they found
has them worried
we have kinder underserved children for
antibodies against the coronavirus
and we found that around six times as
many children had had the infection as
would have been expected
this study shows us that children
definitely do get infected
and that they can take the infection
home with them
that so many of the samples from the
children tested positive
came as a surprise to professor ziegler
who headed the study
she thinks that in many cases the
children only had mild symptoms or none
at all
so the infection wasn't detected
first we had no idea what the rate of
undetected cases was
but now we see that it's six times
higher that can reflect the fact that
children tended not to be tested as
often
so the number of cases was
underestimated
that children often don't get tested is
something this father experienced
when coveted 19 broke out in his son's
daycare center
it was mainly the educators who got
tested the children were just sent home
to quarantine
yeah i have to say that i was concerned
so we decided to play it safe and have
the children and ourselves tested
so as to have certainty
it turned out that both his children had
indeed been infected
even though they exhibited no symptoms
nevertheless the local health authority
didn't have all the other children
in the day care center tested jurgen
hastenback says
it should have i just filmed
this i think it was a big mistake not to
test the children apart from it
another thing hustan bag can't
understand is that although adults are
being told
to not meet up in their free time in the
daycare center all the children are in
one big group
rather than in small groups
of course not every risk can be
eliminated says professor ziegler
who carried out the munich study but she
says that if the government wants to
keep
schools and daycare centers open as long
as possible
they have to institute stricter hygiene
rules
we have to assume that children
definitely also get this disease
and i think that we have to take more
precautionary measures in schools and
day
smaller groups social distancing hygiene
ventilation should apply there too
just like everywhere else because
children
also contribute to the spread of the
infection
so that means that at present adhering
to strict hygiene rules
and carrying out more covert tests in
suspected cases
is probably the best way to keep
infections and day care centers
to a minimum and for more i'm joined now
by donna farber professor at the
department of
microbiology and immunology at columbia
university and she's also the co-author
of an article on distinct antibody
responses to cyrus cove 2 in children
and adults across the covit 19 clinical
spectrum
and she conducted a study called
children's untrained immune response
seems to be key to eliminating cysco
ii a lot to talk about here and that
would be the very first question so from
what we've heard
um children infected with cove too
they often don't show any symptoms why
is that
well there could be two main reasons for
that one is that
the virus just doesn't infect as well so
there might be something about uh the
cells in the
in the respiratory tract of children
that are different that just don't allow
as productive of infection so we still
don't know whether that might be a
reason the other
is that the children mount a very
effective and robust
immune response and are able to clear
the virus before they get
a severe symptoms i mean a child's
immune system
still has to learn a lot as opposed to
that of an adult if i understand that
correctly
and uh right t-cells
seem to play a key role here kids are
better equipped it seems why is that
well children are designed to respond to
new pathogens because they have
a whole arsenal of t
cells that are new t cells that have the
ability to respond to new pathogens
these are called naive t cells and
children are producing these
all the time whereas adults
don't have many naive t cells because
we've
generated memory over our lifetime
and we aren't producing new t cells
anymore so children are well adapted
to respond to new pathogens they have
these new t-cells
they mount a robust response however
adults only have memory cells
and or they have mostly memory cells so
they're going on what they've seen
before
so normally adults are better equipped
to respond to pathogens
that they've seen many times like
influenza or rsv
so compared to a child adults are
responding much more effectively they
don't get as sick because they've seen
these
over time have built up these uh memory
responses which provide protective
immunity whereas children don't
but now we're looking at a situation
where both children or adults
are seeing a new pathogen and now the
children
have all the uh t cells and the new t
cells to respond where adults
are not um they do not have as many new
t cells to respond
but do children they don't do as right
do they also have an advantage when it
comes to
uh the long lasting effects of covid19
and we've heard with adults that
uh there are cases of heart failure
other long-term
health issues they have to deal with
even when
they were hardly ill when they actually
had coveted 19.
what do we know about children so far
well i mean we know that there seems to
be some long lasting effects of
coping 19 even from adults that weren't
hospitalized initially and those are
the certain coagulation defects and it
could be due to the very
strong inflammatory response we know
that there's a lot of
markers and mediators of inflammation
that this virus seems to stimulate
in children that can also happen so
the severe disease in children there is
one manifestation which is called
multi-inflammatory syndrome in children
and that can potentially cause
long-lasting effects although
thus far follow-up uh has not shown that
these children really
have long-lasting effects so initially
they were presented with sort of
cardiac heart problems but so far
this hasn't shown to be long-lasting
about the coagulation defects
certainly young adults have shown that
and have have
have actually developed strokes
but in terms of babies and young
children there's just not enough
evidence to suggest that that's also
happening in the in children
so so uh just very briefly yes or no
basically because there's this big
discussion about
reopening schools and kindergartens yes
or no should we or shouldn't we
i mean i think we need to but we need to
protect uh the children
in terms of i mean we need to to still
be wearing math
and and have these precautions in
schools but
it would be better to open it because
they're they don't seem to be the super
spreaders
all right professor farber there from
columbia university
uh joining us from new york thank you so
much for your time and your insights
well thank you the time
for your questions now and over to our
science correspondent derek williams
is it possible to test positive for
covert 19 and its antibodies at the same
time
tricky question to answer it we need a
quick refresher on the terminology
antibodies are immune system proteins
that can be detected by what are called
serological tests generally from blood
samples
if you have antibodies that are specific
to covet 19
that indicates that you were exposed to
the coronavirus at some point in the
past
whether you develop symptoms or not
diagnostics like antigen and pcr
tests on the other hand are for
detecting the virus
or its genetic material so they're
supposed to tell you
whether you have an active infection
this question
therefore basically boils down to can i
have
an active infection yet at the same time
be producing detectable amounts
of antibodies against it yes
you can but but finding both involves
getting the timing right
um that's because there's some overlap
between when
an infection is in full swing and the
ramp
up of the body's immune response um in
general experts say
it takes a patient's body between one
and three weeks
to produce detectable amounts of the
different
antibodies that play a key role in
fighting off covet 19.
researchers in new york found that even
patients producing antibodies in those
measurable amounts however
could continue to test positive for the
virus for up to four
weeks after their symptoms resolved
what the team couldn't determine though
was whether that
viral genetic material was actually
coming
from active viable virus pcr
testing doesn't tell you that although
that's really
what you want to know it just tells you
whether there are intact pieces
of viral rna in a sample